just just tell me what happens and then
and then I'll try and do it without you
telling me making a big film or series
can be a daunting task and can have some
tensions running high so what big titles
do you think saw these big names walk
offset number one playing The Joker was
no joke actor Joaquin Phoenix took
playing this role very seriously so much
that he found himself walking out of
scenes more than once so what's up with
that director Todd Phillips said in the
middle of a scene Phoenix may just walk
away without saying a word Todd added
Phoenix always left due to his own
performance he was either unhappy with
his current acting or he wasn't in the
right headspace to deliver the scene the
exception seemed to be when Phoenix was
shooting with Robert De Niro number two
Euphoria actor Barbie Ferreira walked
off set at least twice while shooting
the show not including the time Ferreira
had to be helped off after she slipped
and fell twice twisting her ankle during
the filming of the hot tub sequence
filming Euphoria can last for 15 to 17
hours for just one shoot this grueling
practice was part of the New Year's Eve
sequence Jacob elordi was honest about
just how difficult it was saying we shot
that party for over a week so very
quickly it's like being in hell it's
like being in a party that you don't
want to be in at all and you can't wait
to leave number three it really was the
end for Emma in this is the end we see
Emma Watson for a brief Cameo but she
was originally meant to appear on screen
for longer Emma might have realized that
the production was going largely Off
Script and wasn't comfortable working in
that improvisational way the story of
Watson's exit was not entirely clear
until Seth Rogen set the record straight
he'd written it on Twitter Emma Watson
did not storm off the set the scene was
not what was originally scripted it was
getting improvised changed drastically
and was not what she agreed to number
four she had a less than gleeful time
Leah Michelle was not always on the best
of terms with her Glee co-stars but one
specific incident with castmate Naya
Rivera led her to walk off the set one
day some of the cast felt like Leah
Michelle had been performing some Diva
Antics and were annoyed specifically
when she made everyone wait to shoot a
scene while she dealt with personal
matters Rivera finally went to the
producers and warned them that Michelle
was pissing off people and when Leah
Michelle learned about that she left the
set number five he shall not pass sir
Ian McKellen had a hard time filming The
Hobbit director Peter Jackson opted to
use practical effects while making the
Lord of the Rings but decided to use
digital effects while making The Hobbit
Kellen was not into it saying I was
miserable it may be my impression but I
don't remember a green screen on the
Lord of the Rings McAllen became so
frustrated while making The Hobbit that
he broke down saying I cried actually
unfortunately the microphone was on and
the whole studio heard the fact he was
working alone in front of a green screen
almost caused the actor to leave the
movie set for good fortunately Peter
Jackson calmed the actor down number six
she's not ready for her close-up while
filming Game of Thrones when Dame Diane
Rigg was ready to shoot she expected
everyone else to be ready as well her
scene partner Jessica henwick explains
she walked onto the set and she went I'm
ready now the camera crew had to tell
Diana that they weren't ready yet but
Riggs wasn't hearing it roll the cameras
she'd shout and dive right into the
scene Diana did two takes before the
camera operator told her great now we're
going to do a close-up but Diana was
done and moved to leave this set very
slowly henwick said we watched as Diana
Rigg effectively did her own version of
storming off the set but it was at 0.1
miles per hour number seven too close
for comfort add Astra saw Brad Pitt
playing an emotionally distant astronaut
searching for his long-lost father but
the actor may have had a similarly
distraught mental state behind the
scenes Pitt was stressed out over his
divorce with Angelina Jolie and had
stormed offset while shooting a
difficult scene According to some people
on set that day Pitt who was attached to
wires had engaged in heated discussions
with director James Gray who he had
known for decades it seems like Brad's
emotions simply got the best of him that
day number eight it's all fun and games
till someone walks offset while filming
Community Chevy Chase had enough series
Creator Dan Harmon shares some info on
Chase's issue that day writer and
producer Adam County pitched a tag for
the season 3 finale Chase however ever
didn't think it was funny and refused to
shoot the scene when the actor had
walked offset in the past the crew would
pick up his shots later in the week this
time though the set came down after
Chase went home the scene was never shot
and Harman was not happy about it Chase
left the show but returned for a cameo
in season five number nine a 40 million
dollar Escape Plan filming Interview
with the Vampire turned out to be a
miserable one for Brad Pitt was set to
play Louisiana vampire Louis Dupont de
la when he read the script weeks before
production was set to begin he had a few
problems the actor explained in the
movie They Took The Sensational aspects
of Lestat and made that the pulse of the
film but for me there was just nothing
to do you just sit and watch the actor
became so unhappy working on Interview
with the Vampire he even tried to get
out of the project Pitt said one day it
broke me I said I can't do this anymore
how much will it take to get me out
pretty producer David Geffen answered 40
million dollars after that it's not
surprising Brad found it within himself
to stick out the rest of the production
number 10. she had a less than fantastic
time Jessica Alba's decision to leave
the acting world might have been
influenced by her experience working on
Fantastic Four Alba said the director
was like it looks too real it looks too
painful can you be prettier when you cry
cry pretty Jessica the way she was being
directed for the movie made her question
her abilities as an actor Jessica
explained he was like don't do that
thing with your face just make it flat
we can CGI the tears in Alva nearly left
butts ended up finishing the movie
number 11. this actor got Furious Fast
Michelle Rodriguez took a look at the
script of the Fast and the Furious and
she hated the direction the writers took
her character Rodriguez was willing to
risk the big paycheck and possibly her
career she said is it realistic for a
Latin girl who's with the AL list of the
alpha males to cheat on him with the
cute boy Michelle explained how strongly
she felt about it saying I basically
cried and said I'm going to quit
Rodriguez did not have the leverage to
get a script change however her co-star
Vin Diesel convinced the actress to
stick around Vin was the first one to
pull me to the side while I was crying
and he just looked at me and said I got
your back chill out and let me handle
this the rest is history number 12 are
you not entertained while filming
Gladiator Russell Crowe had doubts and
questions about the movie script and
stormed off the set when he did not
receive answers according to a
DreamWorks executive Russell was not
well behaved Crowe at first refused to
say in this life or the next I will have
my Vengeance thankfully director Ridley
Scott never lost his temper All Things
Considered we can understand some of
these walk-off moments what about you
would you have done what these actors
did or would you have stayed on set for
these tense moments let us know in the
comments below